the traits I've seen in most successful
people that I've worked for whatever
industry it might be often are that
they're extremely detail-oriented and
they're control freaks but do you feel
that success only follows people who are
workaholics and micromanagers I couldn't
begin to answer that well you could
I don't friend of mine who's the Dean of
our School of Management years ago said
something to me there's one of those
statements that you first hear it you
say that's kind of corny and then you
think about it and say wow that's really
deep you said successful people or
people who know how to work when it's
hard and you know if I said hey why
don't you guys come over this weekend
we'll paint the room I'll get y'all a
pizza and beer and that's like grungy
awful work was that hard just do this a
lot but when you're working on a math
problem and you can't solve it it makes
your head hurt and you want to give up
or you can't figure out how to figure
out fix act too and you just say how the
hell with it
successful people are people who won't
hang in and solve it as long as it takes
and it's a rare quality in people to do
something when they feel like maybe it's
not gonna succeed it probably won't it's
really difficult it's making my head
hurt and still be able to stick to it
under those conditions
I couldn't improve that if I tried that
was great
how about one for me just for the hell
of it something simple
you